PO crossers. These were really the first
intermediate poi tricks that I ever
learned way back in the day, and they're
still a favorite. But how exactly do you
learn how to do them? Well, I got you
covered in this tutorial.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO, sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. In this video, I'm going to walk
you through some basic theory as to why
crossers work. I'm going to talk you
through some exercises that will help
you get a feel for your crossers, and
I'm going to give you a complete
walkthrough on how to do them, plus some
ideas for transitions in and out of
them. But before we dive in, I just want
to give a quick shout out to the friends
of the channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parer,
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video.
And special thanks to the non-b
businessiness friend of the channel,
Pekka Beckanin. Thank you so very much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. So, let's talk for a second
about what exactly is going on in a
crosser. Essentially, in a crosser,
you're moving back and forth between
positions where your upper body is faced
to either your stage right or your stage
left. And in the process, you're
switching whether the poi seem to be
spinning forwards or reverse relative to
you. Regardless of whether you're
turning from the side where the poi
appear to be spinning forwards or they
appear to be spinning reverse. Either
way, you're going to be paying attention
to whichever hand and po are on the side
of your body that's in the direction
that you're about to turn in. So, for
example, if I'm about to turn to my
stage left side, I want to pay attention
to the point when my right hand poi is
going across the midsection of my body.
This is an opportunity for me to turn my
entire body over to stage left and
complete the turn. Likewise, when I'm
turning back to stage right, I want to
pay attention to when my left hand po is
moving in that direction. And when that
happens, I want to follow it all the way
around to complete the turn. Performing
a crosser is really just alternating
back and forth between these two turns.
Crossers are an example of what we call
poi reels. That is moves where the poi
are switching back and forth across our
body in something like a two beat weave.
We first learn how to do reels at the
beginning of our flow journeys, usually
with the poi spinning in together time,
same direction. And we can also perform
them with our poi in split time, same
direction. That is when the poi are
always pointing away from each other.
Crossers are a specialized case of this
where we have our arms crossed as we're
performing one of those split time same
direction reels. And that also means
that we have a little bit of a challenge
because in this case we can no longer
use the entirety of our arms, wrists,
and hands to keep the poi in plane.
Instead, we have our arms in what I like
to call a reduced mobility space. That
is a space where we only have our wrists
and hands to guide the poi through the
air. And in order to get down crossers,
we have to learn how to maintain plane
control in one of these reduced mobility
spaces. Now, we can start to get a feel
for how this trick works by practicing
each of these reels with each hand
independently. So, for example, I can
take my right hand here and spin the poi
around clockwise relative to me. And I
can move it all the way over to my stage
left. And from here, practice doing what
I would think of as being a reverse
tic-tac or a reverse tube beat. That is,
as I'm spinning the poi reverse relative
to me, I'm crossing it back and forth
across my body. So, relative to you,
it'll look like it's doing this. Now,
with it over on my left hand side, I'm
going to bring my hand closer and closer
to my left shoulder until I can reach
out and actually touch it. Now, you'll
note when I start touching that
shoulder, it means I'm going to have to
start moving my body back and forth to
help keep the poi moving. I can do the
same thing with my left hand here,
reaching all the way over to my stage,
right, and practicing doing a forwards
tic tac. Again, relative to you, it's
going to look like this, where it
crosses back and forth across you. And
I'm going to practice moving my hand
closer and closer to my right shoulder
until I can actually touch my right
shoulder. And once again, it means that
I have to pivot my upper body back and
forth in order to keep it moving. All
right. So, technically, you could
actually just practice doing each of
these reels one by one and then work on
performing them together. And
eventually, this probably will work. But
personally, I think the better option
for getting down this trick is to
practice getting down your crossed arm
planes. Both spinning the PO forwards as
well as reverse. Here's what that looks
like. I'm going to start off faced over
towards my stage right with my two po
spinning split time same direction
forwards at my side. I want them to be
even with my shoulders and perfectly
straight vertical. From here, I'm going
to go ahead and cross my arms. And I
want to try and keep the two poi once
again spinning vertical on my sides like
so. This is going to take practice and
lots of it. But ultimately, you want to
get to a point where you can keep the po
spinning for a total of 10 beats without
hitting yourself and keeping your timing
consistent. And once you've got things
down on your forward side, it's time to
learn the reverse side. So at this point
I'm going to turn towards my stage left
and I'm going to get my poise spinning
reverse split time same direction at my
sides. Once again I want to make sure
that they are parallel about shoulders
width apart. And from here I'm going to
go ahead and cross my arms. Once again
you probably want to make sure that
you've got the same arm on top whether
you're facing your forwards or your
reverse direction. But either way,
again, you want to try and keep your
planes straight vertical on this reverse
side. You also, just like you did on the
forward side, want to make sure that you
can get down 10 reps cleanly without the
PO hitting you or without losing your
timing. Cool. So, once you've got both
the forwards and the reverse sides down,
it's time to work on that turn that
takes you back and forth between them.
Here's how it's going to work. I'm going
to go ahead and start off on my forward
side over here. And I'm going to pay
attention to when my right hand po,
which confusingly enough is now on my
left, is going to be passing by my left
hip. It happens right there, there.
There. When that happens, what I'm going
to try and do is let my entire body
follow it around to my reverse side.
Now, you'll notice as I'm performing
this turn, there's a moment when I'm
kind of pausing here in wall plane and I
have each of the poi pointed off to
their own individual sides before I let
that right hand poi come around back
past my left shoulder and complete the
turn. So, I would recommend counting
down to learn this, thinking that you're
going to make the turn in three, two,
one, and turn all the way around to your
stage left. Awesome. And now that you're
on your stage left, it's time to learn
the turn back to your stage right. So,
as that left hand po, which again,
confusingly enough, is now on my right
side, is going up and over my shoulder,
I am going to turn with it. And again,
for a moment, I'm going to have the two
poi out in wall plane here, pointed away
from each other before I let the left
hand poi go down past my right hip. So
al together here I'm going to think I'm
going to count down 3 2 1 and follow it
all the way around to my stage right. So
you want to work on going back and forth
between these two sides counting off
three 2 one turn to stage left and three
2 one turn to stage right 3 2 one turn
to stage left three two one back to
stage right. When you can do 10 reps of
that comfortably, you want to go down to
only doing one, two, and one, two, one,
two, and one, two. And then you want to
go down to just doing a single bead on
each side. Thinking one turn, one turn,
one turn, one turn. And once again, when
that gets to feel comfortable, you're
going to think that you're just going to
swap off immediately. Follow the right.
Follow the left. Follow the right.
Follow the left. And when you get to
that point, congratulations. You are
doing a crosser. Nicely done. So, I will
say when I see people learn crossers and
have things go wrong, it's usually one
of two problems. And here's how to fix
them. So, first and foremost, a lot of
people when they learn how to do their
crossers kind of move their bodies
around a little too much like this. This
is really helpful if you're say going to
learn a straight jacket instead of a
crosser, but really isn't necessary for
a crosser itself. And really what this
comes down to is the person is just
trying to put a little bit too much
movement into this. Really, when you're
performing crossers, you should just be
able to pivot your upper body back and
forth right in place like this. You
don't need level changes in order to get
there. And yes, I know it's me of all
people telling those of you out there
not to put a level change in, but with
crossers, you really don't have to. So,
if you are one of these that is going
around in big circles like this, try to
minimize your movement and instead do
just a focus shift with your head and
shoulders. Stage right, stage left,
stage right, stage left. And keep your
shoulders level the entire way through.
The other thing that I see happen is
people will get into this kind of
position right here where they have
their planes kind of a little wonky on
diagonals. And this springs from not
committing to keeping their hands tucked
up tight next to them. Something goes
wrong as they're going through the turns
where they try to keep their arms pushed
away from themselves in order to avoid
the PO hitting them.
The solution to this one, honestly, is
to spend more time practicing with your
arms crossed and really, really, really
settle in to having both of your arms in
contact with your chest. It's only once
you get comfortable with that that
you'll be able to perform a crosser with
your arms in the proper position and not
locked away from you like so. All right,
so now let's talk some dance options for
your crossers. As with all poi tricks
that involve pivoting your upper body
back and forth, crossers are a great fit
for pod berets. That is these kind of
side steps that involve crossing and
uncrossing your feet as you go from
stage left to stage right. Basically,
you're looking to cross one foot in
front of the other and then open and
then cross behind and then open once
again as you go back and forth. Then of
course you can mix it up and put a foot
behind and open, a foot in front and
open. And you're looking to time that
with those moments when you're turning
your upper body back and forth. So in
those moments where say your left foot
is going to reach around in front of
your right foot, you want to do that
when you're turned to face your stage
right. You open during the turn and you
step back when you are faced to your
stage left. and vice versa. You want to
step that right foot in front whenever
you're turned to stage left open on the
turn and then tuck your right foot
behind your left when you're faced over
to your stage right. So winds up looking
like this. As we take it across, boom.
As we take it across, boom. Nice, right?
So the dance move that most people are
probably thinking of to go with a
crosser is to perform a piouette with
said crosser which of course first means
that you need to know how to do a
piouette. It is helpful to be able to
get up on your tippy toes with one foot
while the opposite foot comes up and
make contact with your knee. As you do
that, you're taking the momentum of your
entire body up and around like so. Now,
the real trick to landing the end of
that piouette is that you're going to
try and actually overturn as you're
doing it. That is, if I'm coming from
facing over to my stage right and going
around, I want to land facing my stage
left. I switch back out of it so quickly
that the audience can't tell. But the
thing is, if I try doing that pure wet
and landing center, I wind up in a spot
where one of my po goes out of plane for
a second. If on the other hand, I
complete the turn all the way to stage
left, it means that I get a much cleaner
plane out of it. So over rotate just
slightly to take yourself all the way to
the opposite side and you'll thank me
for it. Okay, so what about transitions
in and out of your crossers? So, by far
the most common transition I see for
getting into crossers is to get into
them from either a weave or a waist wrap
like so. And it's easy to see why. All
you have to do is wrap your arms around
each other and then just pivot your
upper body back and forth. To get back
out of it, you pause at one side and
open up your arms to allow you to switch
back into your three beat weave. We wrap
the arms around to get to the crosser
and we open them back up to get back
into the waist strap. Nice. Recently in
a choreography video, I performed a
little combo going back and forth
between a 1.5 and a crosser. And I was
asked how it is done. And here's the
answer. Mainly, as I'm going out and
around with my right hand, performing
the pendulum above my left, I let my
left hand hang out underneath my right
armpit for an extra beat. And then I can
bring the right hand as it comes down
and around into the crosser by bringing
it up past my left shoulder. So again,
I'm going to let the right hand go over
and drop down around as my left hand
hangs out in my armpit. And that brings
me into the crosser. To come back out,
all I need to do is spread my arms
across and go back into the 1.5. Easy
peasy. Cool. So, I hope this was
helpful. not just for getting down your
crossers, but also for showing you some
things that you can do with them. If you
went out and uh used these tips to learn
yourself some crossers, be sure to tag
me in any videos that you take showing
yourself doing this move. I am
Drexfactor on most platforms. I'd love
to see your hard work. Did you get
anything out of this video? Please make
sure to like, share, comment, and
subscribe to help other people find it
and of course to help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my Flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much.
You rock. And if you would like to get
your name in the credits or access to a
host of other awesome rewards, you can
do so by checking out my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorploy.
I will include a link to it down in the
description or up in the cards. Be sure
to help support my work and my mission,
and we'll all spread the love of flow
throughout the world together. And if
you already have your crossers down and
would like to check out a move that
those crossers are helpful in getting
down, I will go ahead and link to a
tutorial for the Nevisol body tracing
hybrid that I did just a couple weeks
ago up here on screen as well as down in
the description. Thank you so much for
watching this video. Make sure to get
out and flow yourselves today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon. Take
care now. Peace.